Sieci neuronowe to potężna klasa algorytmów uczenia maszynowego
i występują w wielu odmianach
nie ma możliwości, żeby w filmie wprowadzającym
poświęcić sieciom neuronowym należytą uwagę
w takim jak ten — omówimy tu tylko kilka kluczowych elementów
sieci neuronowej i ogólny przepływ pracy
żebyśmy mogli zrozumieć, jak obliczenia kwantowe mogą się do tego przyczynić
sieć neuronowa to spójny graf neuronów
neuron to w zasadzie po prostu coś, co przechowuje liczbę
a ta liczba często nazywana jest aktywacją — czyli tym, jak bardzo
neuron jest włączony lub wyłączony
neurony są pogrupowane w warstwy
pierwsza warstwa to warstwa wejściowa
a ostatnia to warstwa wyjściowa
pomiędzy nimi są warstwy przetwarzające, zwane
warstwami ukrytymi — aktywacja
warstwy wejściowej jest po prostu ładowana bezpośrednio z danych do analizy
na przykład z jasności pikseli na obrazie
aktywacje następnej warstwy ukrytej są wyznaczane
przez neurony w warstwie wejściowej
oraz przez wagi symbolizowane przez linie łączące wszystkie neurony
warstwy wejściowej ze wszystkimi neuronami
następnej warstwy — innymi słowy, aktywację neuronu
w warstwie ukrytej wyznaczamy
przez ważoną sumę wszystkich
aktywacji wejściowych — możemy też
zastosować bias, czyli przesunięcie
możemy chcieć aktywować neuron
w warstwie ukrytej nie tylko wtedy, gdy ważona suma jest
dodatnia, ale dopiero gdy przekroczy duży próg
następnie często stosujemy skomplikowaną funkcję, żeby uzyskać aktywację
między zerem a jedynką, taką jak tangens hiperboliczny
albo czasem inaczej —
rektyfikowana jednostka liniowa — nie musisz się tym teraz
za bardzo przejmować — jedyne
co ważne do zapamiętania w związku z tymi funkcjami
to to, że są nieliniowe
dzięki czemu sieć jako całość zawiera zarówno liniowe
jak i nieliniowe elementy
ta sama ważona suma aktywacji, tym razem
zaczynając od aktywacji
pierwszej warstwy ukrytej i nowych wag
rozciąga się aż do kolejnej warstwy ukrytej
to trwa aż do ostatniej warstwy, czyli wyjścia
warstwa wyjściowa ma neurony odpowiadające
kategoriom, a aktywacje mówią nam
jak bardzo sieć jest pewna klasyfikacji
więc kategorie wyjściowe w analizie obrazu mogą być na przykład:
pies, kot, chomik i tak dalej
a aktywacja równa 0,95 na
neuronie „pies" oznaczałaby wysoki stopień pewności, że
obraz przedstawia psa — możesz zainicjować sieć neuronową
losowym zestawem wag
i biasów albo ze znanych rozsądnych wartości startowych
ale potem chodzi o to, żeby sprawdzić
jak dobrze twoja sieć neuronowa klasyfikuje rzeczy
i ją poprawić — używamy funkcji kosztu, żeby opisać
jak bardzo nasza sieć neuronowa odbiega od
poprawnej klasyfikacji — polega to na wyznaczeniu
różnicy między prawdziwą wartością dla obrazu
powiedzmy wartością jeden na neuronie
dla psa i zerem na wszystkich innych neuronach wyjściowych
a wartościami przewidywanymi
sumujemy po wszystkich kategoriach
śledzimy więc nie tylko to, czy właściwa kategoria była
najbardziej aktywna, ale też możemy
śledzić, czy błędne aktywacje maleją
sumujemy po wszystkich przykładach w naszym zbiorze treningowym
i otrzymujemy koszt — następnie
zmieniamy parametry, takie jak wagi w każdej warstwie
między wszystkimi neuronami i biasy na każdym z nich
do szukania lokalnego minimum funkcji kosztu
używa się klasycznych procedur optymalizacji
jeśli nic nie zostanie zrobione, żeby zmniejszyć złożoność tego problemu
możesz sobie wyobrazić, jak
astronomiczną przestrzeń parametrów tutaj tworzymy
weźmy sieć neuronową zaprojektowaną do analizy obrazów
z zaledwie tysiącem pikseli — taka sieć mogłaby mieć tysiąc
neuronów wejściowych, tylko jedną warstwę ukrytą
i binarne wyjście, jak kot lub pies
to najprostszy możliwy przypadek
a i tak odpowiada macierzy tysiąc na tysiąc
czyli milion wag między warstwą wejściową a ukrytą
i kolejne dwa tysiące między warstwą
ukrytą a wyjściową
możliwe, że jeszcze tysiąc lub
więcej biasów — a więc ta prosta sieć neuronowa odpowiadałaby
ponad milionowi parametrów — choć uczciwie mówiąc
nowoczesne algorytmy zazwyczaj stosują uproszczenia
w klasycznych sieciach neuronowych
i istnieją całe dziedziny poświęcone temu, żeby tę minimalizację
uczynić możliwą, a nawet wydajną
ale faktem pozostaje, że jest to bardzo
wielowymiarowy problem
a trenowanie sieci neuronowej
może być bardzo czasochłonne
i kosztowne — kwantowa sieć neuronowa, czyli QNN
działa tak, że najpierw ładuje dane wejściowe
a następnie stosuje quantum circuits
odpowiadające wagom między warstwami
i na końcu warstwę pomiarów
kilka kluczowych rzeczy na ten temat — ładowanie danych
i ważenia to operacje liniowe
ale pomiary są nieliniowe
więc tak jak w klasycznych sieciach neuronowych mamy
zarówno liniowe, jak i nieliniowe elementy
poza tym circuit wag
nadal ma parametry wariacyjne
więc klasyczna minimalizacja nadal musi być przeprowadzona
oczywiście to tylko wierzchołek góry lodowej, jeśli chodzi o kwantowe sieci neuronowe
ale mamy nadzieję, że będziesz dalej zgłębiać zastosowania
kwantowych sieci neuronowych
i inne zastosowania kwantowego uczenia maszynowego
razem z IBM Quantum